watch seminomics conjecture and the
bourgain slicing problem
and uh walls will give the talk uh
remotely
close yours
thank you thanks can you hear me
yup
yeah very good okay yeah so indeed i
want to talk about bogans as in problem
and the kls conjecture
uh which is sort of a polylog and this
is a joint work with joseph
and actually i want uh first to thank
the organizers for inviting me to speak
about this topic
um this is not a completely obvious
choice of a topic for a workshop on
quantum and uh crypto analysis
and my hope is that um you guys would
ask me questions and make comments and
stop it whenever you want and also there
is a chat in q a so people can interact
using this uh way too so understand
there is a microphone microphone going
around and that is being passed around
so if anyone has anything to say then
please ask for them i can
and and ask it okay
so so so let me start so uh what's the
what's the bourgeoisie problem
so that's the following question
um
is it true
so this from the eighties
came to its release work on maximum
functioning quality and he asked is it
true that for any uh convex set
k
this convex and has volume one rn
and n is a large number dimension should
be sort of allowed numbers is common in
complexity and fixed dimension is a
trivial question
uh
you can find the higher plane section
whose volume
the volume of the intersection of k and
h is at least c
for universal constant uh
[Music]
c so can you find
uh your convex set and just you want to
find any higher plane
h
well the volume should be at least
universal
okay so so so this is google's housing
problem
and it may look like a riddle uh if it's
the first time you see it but it
actually does a few um consequences and
implications and and relations to other
problems in comics robot and high
dimensions
let me just
tell you about some equivalent
formulations
um
to demonstrate it's all in the theory
so the first one formulation
is is is um the corrected boson petty
problem
so those are petty problems
in from the 50s
uh uh about different so suppose that
you have uh suppose that k and t are two
convex sets
in rn let's make them certainly
symmetric although uh
center is fine but the doji is is fine
uh and assumes that for any
hyperplane through the origin
if you take the volume intersection of k
with this hyperplane it is smaller than
the volume so i'm going to deal with
this higher plane if i put these two
bars i mean the size of the object so
it's n minus one dimensional volume here
must be right it's a higher plane so you
know that's for all sections of cases
uh so is it true
that the volume of k
is followed by some universal constant
times the volume of t
it was the first conjunction of constant
one and this is indeed cool two in some
cases if k is the gradient borrow or
cross point or then it's through it
constant one
but uh after lots of work it has been
discovered that this is true in
dimensions one two three and four but
phone five and above it's just false in
fact dimensional 20 and above the
counter exactly is simply the cube and
the equilibrium ball
um so k should be the um cube here
this is and if it's
a constant then then this is going to be
important
second current formulation
is a let's say refined minimum ellipsoid
or m ellipsoid
so this is the following question
so again k in rn is convex uh volume one
[Music]
uh and the question is does there exist
an ellipsoid
an elixir of volume one
start that
okay volume one so that if you intersect
with k it captures okay so the volume is
one
and what you want is that if you
intersect k with some large group of the
ellipsoid by a constant factor this is
the volume at least one half
okay so this this is going to be a
starting problem um and and if you put
here uh power one over n then this would
be this is true this is the minimum
ellipsoid but without this power this is
not normal usually you can capture half
of the muscle of a convex setting an
ellipse out of roughly the same volume
the third kind of formulation is the
silvester problem
which is um
the following question
so let's sample let's select uh n plus
two
uh iad independently is real points
random points in some convex set
okay now rn convex
and you ask for the probabilities that
they're in convex position
so this is the probability for convex
position what does it mean
it means that uh saying the plane it is
four points in that convex position if
no point is in the convex hell of the
other points this is a convex position
uh and and the classic problem is equal
with the question whether this actually
the complement whether one minus p of k
um to power one over n
is uh
theta of one of the root of n so this
bounded for environment from below some
universal constants times one over root
of n
that's another uh formulation and i
think the last one would be
about the entropy and covariance
so this is um
[Music]
this is about
low
[Music]
density
um
okay so what is a local gear density um
this means that um
this means that it's uh
e to minus h
where h is a convex function
so for so it looks like like like the
gaussian side or something this is a
gaussian is not concave and also the
informational convex set
is
again low concave and this class of
local densities like amount of vectors
is the rather is this this table under
voice operation so if you uh
take the sum of two dependent
logarithmic vectors again okay if you
project it to a lower dimensional space
it
there's a covalent class of uh
distribution which includes
uniform versions of convex sense
and the question
so uh is it true that you can determine
so you know what's an enthalpy of a
random vector is if
if then if x is density f
then the enthalpy is just the integral
of you know what what's much you know
f on r
and and and the question
is it true that for any low concave
x in our m
you can determine its entropy
with some small error
by the covariance matrix so is it true
that the entropy vector is half of the
logarithm of the level of the covariance
matrix of x that's a small l of n
okay and covariance should i define so
there's no interaction at all in the
first limits of the lecture which is a
bad sign so please say something in
there
so this is a matrix and the i j is just
you know this is the covariance of uh
this time
and i ing from one to n
[Music]
okay so both entropy is a way to measure
the size of the machine rn so kind of if
it's uniform in some set
then the enthalpy of the distribution is
just the log of this volume of the set
but also the term of the conveyance
matrix is a way to measure the the
support of a random vector
and slicing is about the question
whether you can replace the two more or
less up to up to a small error
okay so these are four current
formulations so all of them are now have
positive ones have two locating factors
the last one up to log log but let me
just to connect two lattices that mean
eddie mark
uh and in fact there are greater excel
than me this audience particularly uh
stephan devitovich
so um
it is not so so they proved regularly
which um um proved based on lots of
others
uh
following conditional statements
that if uh
among all
uniforms will convex
[Music]
difference is maximized
for the cube
so this is a strong form of slicing
problem
for the cube
then a certain old conjecture attribute
minkowski follows so when you call
scalatics conductors followed
um
i guess that um okay i can
tell you about this conjecture if you
want to know the conjecture says that
for any lattice l for the dominant in rn
dominant one
of the volume one
um
um
then the transit of l
intersect a certain set
and that set is is all points in our end
whose geometric average
is at most one half
okay so so um
that's one relation
[Music]
yes
so
hi by the way
yeah yeah i'm great yeah okay um
so
um
is this is this case four is this
is this uh like a restatement
at least for uniform measures and convex
sets is this convex bodies is is this
the same thing as the isotropic constant
conjecture is that is
okay so so that really is fully
equivalent to
up to a constant factor this to this
borgana slicing and all of the other
yeah
yeah
yeah
exactly this is
the topic awesome question
uh right um
[Music]
um
yeah but this is um
so here the scale is it's small the log
of the the the constant so you wanna so
this is known up to
logo again basically because it's
already in the logarithmic scale
because the logarithms the isotopic
constant so if just because greg
mentioned it so the sloping constant of
k
um
is
is the determinant of the covariance
matrix of different solution one k
by one over two n over its volume to the
uh one over n that's the constant of ken
and indeed um when you are uniform the
entropy is just the volume so you see
that these are the same the same thing
that's so isotropic constant is yet
another thing that's in your laundry
list of equivalent to the slicing
conjecture yeah yeah so the number five
thanks to greg yeah so is it true that
uh
that for n so and it's always at least
if this is true it's this universal
constant is it true that um
there's also for any k in our end this
is at most
that's that's defeats the gram
formulation
good okay
um so now is that we walk okay so let's
work with lk or let me let me put it i
okay so let's define um
um i would not talk in the topic because
it'll work it's like in slightly
different it's a criminal universal
constant so i go over all contact sets
and for each
of volume one for each
i try to see what's the
section of largest volume
um
and and that's this one and this one
over that and this is this quantity
and so so and our theorem is that this
is uh
this is bounded by uh constant
to the four times n
okay so so um
up to
log factor you know that for convex set
you can find a section of
volumes at least one over four
previous results so chen
just less than two years ago
uh
the uh very good bound it was a
breakthrough so he got um
uh that is the most um
root of into the root again
so it's more than any power of
absolutely so this is smaller up to uh
this more than any power of of
n which is which was great progress
because the earlier bounds
was um by morgan and myself so beginning
in the 80s
proved that this is the most into the
login and i removed the login
okay so um
[Music]
so this is about um
there's a topic
now um so there is a hierarchy of of
open problems instead of the geometry
and and uh
um
and this last thing is is is not very
high indirectly those are harder
problems and in fact
term one
follows from the relations to uh
two things from from sin shell and kls
so let me explain what these two things
are
um
yes please yes yes a quick question too
so uh
that's the probabilistic does the
probabilistic method give you anything
sort of is there a sort of a simple
bound that you can get
by sort of picking the hyper plane so at
random however you yeah yeah okay so
there is one complete trivial bound is
root so first of all in a fixed
dimension it's liverpool you can find a
trivial bound is that
this here is one of the root of m let's
let's see why right all of autumn is
true why why not i mean easy like the
first thing that you one of them is
because
the euclidean ball
of volume one
has a radio surveillance all right this
this that is people know this seat right
so the queen of volume one is is is
regular
so this would mean that basically if
your product body is volume one then
there is a direction in which the widths
the width is when you take two planes
what's the distance between them so this
is at least one direction where the
width is at most rule of m because
otherwise we have two large volume so if
you have a direction of the width is
rule of m
by forbidding one of the status will be
this one
right okay so that's that's that's
that's the the first uh inbound uh ever
was not even mentioned anywhere in the
literature bulgan got the end of the
quarter
uh which was kind of a non-trivial thing
and at some point
there was three completely different
proofs that literally led to this end of
the quarter so
against proof used uh subtle moon by
telegram and you know major logic
measures energy chaining things like
that
by piecing and then my approach used
this the logarithmical plus transform
and this was another proof uh by the
impala which is that
all of them get into the quarters some
kind of people saw that well maybe
that's another quarter is the right
thing and
the natural counter example
was something like some quantitative
matrices in dimension and square in
dimension and square
root of finding some normal some natural
scale you've seen in in random matrix
theory so somehow this this was a
tempting but no changes found and
actually used things which are not that
far from from what the dd experts tried
and he just
bought this bar and got something which
is way way less than the end of the
quarter
and today we move it a bit further and
get low to log into the force
um more more and if anyone else some
question
okay so so i told you that there's this
ln which is about volumes of sections
and dial key so um there is
okay there are things which are weaker
than all these sort of discussion but
the signature still opener are there is
something called sigma n which is thin
shell
and there is
cn which is uh kls constant cannon
oversee one of which
um
so
um
and and and okay this implication is uh
due to one another and myself
some years ago and this is kind of
simple this is very relatively easy
okay so what are these things cincinnati
um
so um
so definition so let me um
let me say that that um say um
[Music]
a random vector x or probability measure
uh would you prefer another vector
i'm not clear
um so okay so mu so probability measure
mu is is
isotropic
uh
is
isotropic if
if it is centered and covalence is
identity
and cohan's identity so this means that
uh
the integral of x i d mu x
zero and the integral of x x j is the
the delta is
okay so this is just means that you
translated your distribution made it
centered and then you scale linearly in
some orthogonal directions and made
valences equal one in all directions
okay so this is your
and now
the the the essential constant so if if
mu is local carbon isotropic
so normalized if essential constant
sigma of mu is just the variance
of the euclidean unknown
okay
uh so
and actually it's also equivalent to
reversal constant by uh that's a linear
quantity for polynomials
to the values of the square root of
square divided by n so what is the
meaning of this quantity here
um so let's try the door picture
so maybe this is the uh the axis and and
and mu is a measure here and since it's
isotropic
uh you know that the expectation of x
squared is n it's exactly n so
basically the quantum effects is
typically
around rural fan that's the scale in
which this this
distillation leaves
and um what the essential conjecture
suggests
is that there is our two s
two concentric uh euclidean balls
so this both of them are
of affirmative and the width the
distance here is sigma of mu
and half of the mass
most of the mass of of this distribution
lies in in this thin spherical shell
between two constraints concentric uh
um but spheres of of
[Music]
the difference is symbols so that's why
it's called essential constant and and
some years ago it was shown that okay
i'll discuss this in a second so that's
the finisher concept of any any
mu
and um
sigma n is just the supremum of sigma mu
or mu in r that's this is this essential
parameter um
sigma mu and the effect that was
discovered like 15 years ago was that
indeed
uh the the shady thing so compared
compared to the radius which is euro fan
most of the mass for local cave cases
indeed containing a spherical shell and
the game is to show it's really seen to
control the exact way the the growth of
this particle sigma okay but the fact
that sigma n is little fruit and is is
kind of
important
okay now what's the ks constant so let
me this is let me start with the
parametric
or cheaper constants in some communities
um
so that's the following
[Music]
quantity so our measure would have a lot
of density
law that's the density
and we defined as a volatile coefficient
to be just um you take all sets
in rn of smooth boundary sub all subsets
so it's one thing and you look at the
following ratio so you look at the
boundary measure so the integral over
the boundary of four divide by the
minimum of mu of a and one minus your
okay so if i do a picture so i have my
convex set and i look on all possible
ways to partitioning in two parts
so that uh the interface will be
minimized
and in fact it is known actually in the
convex it is known that inform is a
okay known um
[Music]
okay this is going to due to a lot of
sterling and zoom from the end of the
90s and uh in the convicts body case and
in the local cave cases it was
generalized by manual minimum
that this if okay it is essentially
enough to consider u equals one half
um so it is
um with some extra little equality
something it is obtained where the
partition is is symmetric half and half
this this ratio here
so that's the isothermic constant from
the distribution i'm sure that
people know that and psi n would be well
the supreme move over sine u over all
your concave support list solutions
okay so that's uh uh mu is local
capability
so these are the the three um
open problems in in in volumetronics in
high dimensions
um
so this is a hyperplane sections this is
thin shell and that's as a permeability
of all possible sets and this is known
that we have these relations
eldan
in
2013 in his phd
proved
the following
important inequality is that that you
kind of can reverse the last this thing
can be reversed up to low this was known
already almost nine years ago
that psi of n is at most up so this
means that up to constant factor uh
sigma n times log n
and for that we invented the method
called uh stochastic localization that
we
might discuss later i think yes
um
and
our theorem
is that um
is that
[Music]
up to polylog factors these things are
are
bounded so cn is the five we get it's
not i'm sure the powers are not
and for c when you get located four okay
so actually use uh dam to get from this
bound to
the
cyan
okay so let me tell you a bit about uh
uh
bounds for sigma any questions about
okay
yeah
um
two two questions one
more strictly mathematical and one maybe
a little bit
just about your opinion um
so there's a way to convert or
approximately convert a log concave
measure to a convex body that's right
you just take extra dimensions and then
you just make it a yeah
surface a surface of revolution so that
you rescale balls according to the
probability of destiny
is this conversion
a universal principle across all of your
talks so that you can always say that
measures are the same topic as convex
bodies for everything you're doing yeah
yeah pretty much so maybe the simply the
log concave measure is a a more
convenient viewpoint but not
fundamentally different i guess is what
you're saying yeah although you can i
mean if you really insist you could find
but but i mean yeah i agree with you
yeah it's the same thing okay measures
okay and i mentioned for me it's more
than the same okay so maybe i have
actually two uh opinion questions rather
than just one okay to follow up on your
first answer
is
do you
do you consider uh log concave measures
a better viewpoint after a while than
convex bodies or uh analytically it's
much more convenient you'll see from the
proof yeah yeah analytically
in my proof yeah you definitely need to
for yeah you have the gaussian you want
the heat flow i mean you don't you don't
if you i mean
many many techniques just
immediately leave the realm of convicted
worries uh okay okay so so even though
it's
even though it's sort of universal
you do like the log concave measure
viewpoint better
yeah okay so my my other opinion
question is that
maybe just one little reminder all of
these conjectures are equivalent to the
constant for convex and follow
conclusions you can prove slicing
forward
sure sure
my other question is um
uh
uh before any of this revolution
you sh you you told me that some people
were starting to to
wonder a little bit about the
the slicing conjecture because it seemed
too strong was your phrase and maybe
it's not true so is it your opinion now
that
that uh
that for
you know the
the
that that probably
that that the that probably you can get
rid of all of these log factors or do
you or does that still
seem too too strong i mean should we do
we understand these conjectures better
by believing them without any of the log
factors
or or uh
or do the or does the revolution with
the log factors is that taken as
evidence that you should even be able to
get rid of the log factors and that
and that the conjectures are really true
without them
um
[Music]
first of all the powers i'm willing to
bet that one so it's fighting for i'm
sure that's another option
um
now there are three conjectures there
by the way if i put something new to be
the i mean the minimum inequality
basically that's the thing which is kind
of weaker than slicing my viewpoint
um
[Music]
i don't i'm it's hard to tell you know
this says that if the polling is hard
enough it's not so important what the
expert sync um
i'm afraid to so some people you know
okay so i don't know kls what conjecture
this is true 95
um
do i what this looks like this looks
strong and this looks
i would not be surprised if slicing is
true for kls i don't see any
[Music]
for careless it looks to me hard at
least
for something it could be even for sigma
for these two things it would be not
um
something
spectacular even there could be some
simple argument that the gold has missed
um it's basically um optimization of
some not that complicated parameters in
the space of uh convict sex after all
well let me let me just put it this way
this is a kind of more
more radical assertion about what people
should believe for for some of the most
famous questions whether it's
uh the riemann hypothesis or p versus np
there's a there's a feeling that you
understand the question better if you
believe the conjecture
oh how about factoring his heart
well
it's not true for all conjectures i mean
particularly if eventually there was a
counter example then in hindsight then
you cannot say that you understood it
better
if you believe the conjecture because of
the wrong answer but certainly the
feeling is that you understand the
riemann hypothesis better if you believe
it yeah
you're not going to go this far with any
of these conjectures
i didn't check 10 to the 10 roots or
anything so
[Music]
okay you're hedging so you you're not
going that far even though you have this
vlog
so but you know i mean somehow somehow i
put a gap between these two things and
that thing so for me
ellen and sigman are more kind of
unless i mean i i think that
let's say i would spend my time with
proving the diesel bound let's say more
than one of them but for sigma cyanide i
just don't know
okay okay thank you that answers the
question my my my but i wouldn't say
that i put more than eight i mean it's
not that i will i don't know
um yeah yeah
uh one good thing about this problem is
that there is kind of a steady progress
noise so if you look on sigma n
then the sigma is basically the roots of
the shell and root wood and bound is a
trivial thing
and and and um
let me just tell you that i mean so so
in 207 uh the first control boundary it
was into the two-fifths plus little of
one
in two nine
bono flare
from paris improved the exponent to c
over a this isn't an improvement it's an
exercise for you okay uh then enter the
third
let's go down on minimum
uh in
two years later
and these two these techniques used and
by the way i i was certainly personally
influenced by peruse
so this was what happened earlier it was
in five so this was he got kind of got
not essential but some kind of large
effort which was really really
influential for him
and but these three things was basically
the same technique which is some kind of
concentration of measurement high
dimensions like that
and as it was
so there was some break of five years
where eldan did this method and then it
was used by limited impala to get the
clean into the quarter so we thought it
screamed at the time
[Music]
[Music]
smaller than uh
it would be uh log into one half
plus or of one
um so this was this was really uh
okay so so if you if you look at these
western statistics so you could conject
yourself i don't know in like
some three four years and it could be
first improvement then i i do believe
that it's not the fire
um
good um
okay so so for now let me discuss a bit
about the other questions about the
formulation of the results and history
and
[Music]
so by the way this i mean it's problems
that the interest seems to these people
some of them are are belongs to the part
of mass i mean computer science having
statistics so it's a problem that has uh
people from different angles uh were
able to make progress here so
yeah it's not that far from
you guys i'm sure
okay so so the project we have our
approach um
[Music]
relies on some functionalities and
probabilities so we use something uh
which we call h minus finding quality
nl dance theorem
okay these are two things that we we
rely on
so let me uh
begin by recording the e point great
constant
so the poincare constant um
i think you i'm sure you know it's your
only graph
so what the polynomials cp mu
is the mean so for improbability measure
this is the minimum number c
for which
the pancreatic quality holds
so i want that for any function f its
variance
should be smaller than this constant c
times
uh the integral of its gradient square
okay so on a graph you sum of all of the
edges look at the difference right and
in the continuing we look at in this
integral of graph square this is called
this is a sub number if you
denote it sometimes by h dot one
okay so that's the point constant
and um
the chiga inequality
may be reversed in the local cave case
uh by the sorts of buzzer and ledu
from the previous century and they say
that that basically the constant up to
universal factors i think four or nine
or something of this sort is basically
this isoparametric constant that we
mentioned earlier okay so
um if you know that your convex set has
good conductance at the um the interface
of two sets of measure one half is
always large then you know that the
spectrum that the perspective the okay
the causal is large and the other way
around after constant factors these
these things are
um are the same
and um
the ks conjecture
so i didn't say that um
it says that okay psi n is bound but it
was a constant
uh but it also it also means that um
linear functions
nearly saturate the program equality
um so
why because if your function is x1 this
is a linear function just x1
right so if you took x1
nothing still
yeah then its grain is just
this is just one according to this one
and and it's the topic it's values also
so these two things are one
ah and and the conjecture is that well
this is after the external case okay so
so that's the the kind of version of
which uh conjecture
okay um good now i want to dualize this
h1 norm if you would allow me um so my
point of view is a bit kind of function
analytic uh but there is also a lot of
probability so i think this this um
point of view kind of confronts you over
here so the dual line is the uh h minus
one one so for if you have some function
f um
we can make it integral zero
so it's not that otherwise it's infinity
um then the h minus one what is it
so it's the dual line to the h one
answer i look at the super mover the
overall functions of the integral of u
times f
over all functions with h1 long is is at
most one
okay so this is a dual node okay why is
it what's the meaning of this term
um
say so this is this is the intestinal
transport cost actually this is the
meaning of this node
so if you look on on um
if you love your measurement mu
and you want to find and you look
another measure one plus epsilon f times
so this is this is again probability
because of this condition
and you want to say what's the best way
to couple them so as to minimize the
square there to distance
then this this is called the vasodilator
this is this then this is indeed roughly
epsilon times the number
okay so that's the meaning of this
inverse solved norm
okay
now there is an equation called h minus
y inequality
um
[Music]
so it was um
woven by myself online for convex sets
and by bart and myself in the local
education indeed
no this is
um the same proof not not that
complicated and
the thing is that if mu is no concave
bus just a second so
can you can you remind us of what what
the definition of h1 norm is ah integral
yeah i would just not write it okay let
me definitely you know let me write it
within you okay but integral
is good good enough right sorry that's h
minus one more
just the integral of graph maybe i'll
put it in bigger letters
integral of god you square smaller than
one
okay that's
so you you
all right so so the
the h1 the sum of one norm is okay what
the one means first derivative
that's what it means so functions in h1
mean the first derivative the l two norm
then to almost the first derivative
that's that's the one here
and that's the minus one is kind of the
ethno of the minus
um but this is this is it okay so you
you just look at the dual line take the
super of the of this color product in l2
over all functions was
grabbing
at most one
that's the h minus one
never seen that huh um um um
okay um
and and transport i think right
transport is something that people
people
it's very dramatic thing right you don't
want to couple two measures and to
minimize the distance that's something
that people
you know
see quite often
um so that's the meaning of this node
um
okay and and and for logo
measures um
this knows behave there is a nice thing
which is that for any function f
its variance
is at most
the h1 norm of the gradient of the
function
and and this means that this is the sum
this means this is the sum of the
coordinates h minus one number of
degrees of the coordinates
and uh maybe let's assume uh okay
assuming that the integral is zero
otherwise it's infinity so it's not
assuming the legal graph is zero
otherwise
okay so um we claim something a bit
strange so um
let's let's look at units grad f is one
over meters because we divide by
something but the h minus one room
exactly brings the back so so this is
the same units as the left-hand side so
it could have this is this is not the
other this is just for local
okay
um
and uh should i uh
let me just okay let me just show kind
of what techniques are being used just
tell you
the proof is really simple i mean it's
so general it must be simple no constant
um so there is you know when you work
with graphs you have that you know that
the progress constant is one over the
first i can remove the adjacency matrix
right of the
um this is looks like a spectral thing
so what's that this is matrix of a
measure well the general is an operator
which is this operator
it's the passion of mu
uh plus grad u times grab log flow
okay this is the plus type operator
associated with the measure mu it's
something called focal planck
there are some names that you can attach
to it
and and the the the interesting thing is
that there is some kind of there is some
uh in the concave case there is a bokeh
formula
[Music]
which says that
for any u the integral of l u square
so it exists in there in this heat world
even what the purple but about in the
scale but it's kind of in the continuous
case it's much more developed so this is
just an identity it's you take the
second derivative of the function
and you add the mu everything and that
if if raw is e to minus psi
then this is the hessian of psi
right you grad you
and this is positive
in the logan cave case so you have this
inequality
and you just dualize it
in some
using such definition and you get i mean
it's really a few lines if you if you
are familiar with these techniques kind
of classical functional analytic
techniques
okay so so we have some kind of
relationship between the violence and
the transferred cost of the grain of the
function right some something else
now what we're going to do we're going
to combine
a dance theorem
with h minus one so so far
um done is a black box because i didn't
tell you about the organization but each
one is finding quantitative hopes you
kind of um
[Music]
it's not that difficult
so how would i combine these two things
together um so i have a measurement you
look okay isotropic right and i want to
prove it's in shell constant bound
things like that okay
whatever
let me take one a measure which is
pretty much the worst possible the one
with the largest
essential constant okay so the thin
share of sigma mu up to some factor five
or two or one perception
okay is as large as possible
okay
now uh
so what do we know by l done which is
still black box so we know that um
psi n up to log is is in sigma roughly
the same sigma square is at least sine
square over log n
and and this is sigma mu of square okay
which as you'll remember that's the
variance
of x square
okay
sticking with my definition
it should be an
investment with a different division
but that's this is clear
so let's divide this that's the
definition of sigma you the values of
this problem the bits of the function
but now let's use this h minus y
inequality with the function x square
the function x squared is a very simple
gradient it's 2x right
so this is the most one over m times the
eight four over n i'm sorry
times the h minus one
of this random vector x
right that's that's something um
[Music]
helpful
um so
this implies
that if i look at the
okay let me show the 800
let's look at the average of the h1
minus
minus one of the coordinate functions
which have mean zero because the measure
is centered
uh a trivial fact that this is exactly
uh bounded by the quantity constant
because for if you remember i mean i'm
sure it's difficult unless you are
really geniuses to immediately
understand that when you do allies and
you look at the proper inequality um you
get that h1nosman norm is it at most the
constant times the electron but believe
me it's just one line okay just this
very simple thing that
the h1 is one of the most the progress
times the l2 that's a triviality it's
always true but
what we get from this chain of we get a
lower bound right for this set and what
we get this is at most um so at least
even inside let me put the concrete
constant which is slightly could be
smaller than psi n over log square m
okay so this means
that we even if we didn't start the
proof just plugged in l down and we
already know that up to log factors
linear functions
nearly saturate the h minus y equality
[Music]
nearly saturate
sub to rate
the h minus one quantity and
if you remember the ks conjecture
is saying that clear functionalisatory
the pancreatic world
so we kind of
when you just use eldon and
transform you kind of immediately see
that well up too long things look pretty
good right up to long you know the
infection is
saturated minus 20 so need to find some
way to kind of dualize it this is this
fact so this will be our approach
okay so let's look at the um
spectral decomposition
of x i i don't know any one of them
one of these functions with respect to
the operator l
what does it mean special composition
so i put let's okay i'll
i call it mu of x i it's a measure on r
it is called the spectral measure
um of x i
and basically puts ignore these things
it's basically you go over the eigen
eigen functions of
the operator l these are the eigen
functions and i put uh i put the the the
i put the this is this is that this is
the eigenvalues of l minus l these are
the eigen functions
and you know i take the decomposition of
this formula basically look at the
the mass of the l they must look at the
uh
enter the composition of x and this
basis and these are the the size of the
coefficients right so for instance i
know that your x i
of of r equals one because it's an l2
function it's normal
okay so this is a measure it's a measure
and let me draw this measure
so
i mean okay let me know the density of
this measure just discrete measure but
let me go suppose you kind of convert
the tiny gaussian or something because i
want to do this picture so that's this
measure
it's density kind of so how does it look
so i've
three scales that i care about there is
lambda one the first eigenvalue which is
one of the pokemon consonants that is
say times slog square
and there is one one
big big big
scale of this graph
and this is some mass there is some this
is new effects like the total integral
is one here okay
and what do i know so first of all the
mass of moment
[Music]
uh i know that the mass cannot i mean
they must start with lambda one because
there's no space in here this is the
spectral gap
and i know that the median
so here there is at least half of the
mass
y so at least half of the mass is below
log n times lambda 1.
why because um
we know that the harmonic not just the
media
even the harmonic average so so um so
the h minus one norm what's the meaning
of the h minus one norm
of
of x i is just the integral of um
sort of this measure of one over lambda
okay
and i know okay if i put maybe i put it
uh um
let me put minus two
to be the harmonic average
okay and we know that the harmonic
average is at most uh lambda 1 times log
square n by by what and by the second
word after so we know that which is good
this is not that big
and uh
on the other hand if i just take the
expectation of this measure
um
then the meaning of this expectation is
if you go over the eigenvalues of what
do you do you take the operator l you go
over all eigenvalues you just put mass
which is eigen value at each one then
what you would get is just the h1
of mu which is one
so i have kind of median versus
expectation
so i know that the
the expectation of this measure is one
but the median is is pretty small i mean
it's lambda one over and and so i want
to show that this cannot happen that
lambda one is kind of big if this these
things happen okay so that lambda is
actually also up to polylobe is close to
one so that that's our situation
so what we actually would like to kind
of dump the high frequencies right i
want to apply kind of heat so that's
what i tell you right i want to
this is the only way i know i want to
apply some heat flow
and say that these destroy high
frequencies because they annoy me i want
to show that do not matter that much
okay so let me tell you uh
things about um
the heat flow
in rn
um
okay so this is a very common technique
in analysis uh also uncommon talks a bit
no
b
um so what do you do
we have the gaussian measure
this is a
gaussian measure in rn
um i can still write the density if i'm
so it's well okay gamma s of min
[Music]
zero and
variance s
okay so that's a measure of
um
[Music]
of
root of s with kind of okay in our end
and now what's the heat flow differences
with the gaussian so given mu
mu is given
now i look at mu of s which is mu
convert with gamma s by by convex
voltage so concave now
and i look at uh i also want to look at
the ps operator
which is um okay this i i looks like
what do i do why do i need to define
psms that's because ps
is a contraction
from l 12 mu s
to l of mu um
this is
um
so i mean this means that uh well
so the integral of ps of f squared mu
is smaller than the integral of f square
d mu s and this is for any mu and e f
it's completely simple very very simple
okay and and and
functionalize this people just dualize
whatever they see so let's do a sps
let's look at a joint operator so we
define
qs
to be the so-called adjoint operator
from
l2 mus 12 mu no sorry no this is the
good thing for this s goes frozen yeah
this
[Music]
and um it's not exactly still i mean
it's actually a very simple thing us of
f is just ps of f4 divided by pso4 it's
a very simple formula
well while it will minus the density of
dimensional mu okay
so that's some some operator
and
its meaning
uh is is true actually um
[Music]
time inverted
stochasticalization so now let me use
this opportunity to
[Music]
tell you about these things so actually
this point of view is from
papers at the head with uh putra
putriman
uh
bit after chance result
um so so
q so for any f q s of f this
operators that we defined the joint
so this is basically the
if s is one over t
this is the expectation
of the integral of f
times something called pt of x
okay
uh
or pt
um
where
there is is that that civilization
okay what do i mean by that's called
what is large differentialization
um so it's something um
it is stochastic process okay so um okay
so okay let me use the last few minutes
to tell you about this this last
quantization
um
so
uh
so pt uh is a stochastic process of
probability distribution in rn
and actually just a point of view for
analyzing the heat equation
um
[Music]
of probability measures in rn
the density is needed in rn
so how
how does it work so uh let me write okay
i'll write this as a differential
equation because many people know this
even in
the skit world so um
so i have some volume motion bt
and
i begin at time 0 i begin with my my p0
is just wrong
and then at any little time interval
i'm going to uh
multiply by my my function
and eight is the byte center of pt
and what is the meaning of of this
equation that means that i begin with
the probabilities of rn okay
and then i flip a coin
and i go to my coin i multiply the
distribution by in a five function
in kind of a random direction
and you know and still i'm guaranteed
that the total number will remain one so
if you want
then
p t plus epsilon of x is roughly
pt of x
times one plus
well not normal okay uh x minus the body
center
time theta
well these are kind of this puzzle minus
that this is a random direction
something of this sort okay so i
multiply it each
ignore the waterfall i just multiply the
distribution each time by some random
functional and this is very helpful
for analyzing uh the heat flow
um for instance because of the formula i
will show you about right you get it
from from the heat from some kind of
reverses the
the time of the heat flow and let you
use that as a pistol to measure uh uh uh
in a very clean way
okay so what the how would they dump
frequencies and things like that just
including hippie flow so there is the
following proposition
which i uh formed from uh my people with
putterman which says that um
that if any any if you is not concave
and it takes any function uh
to know is one
um
integral of f with zero
um then
for any any any number s if i look
at q s of x choice of f sorry
so this thing um
actually this is this is low convex in s
that's that's the two thing
um there is some second derivative
saying that there's a much of the bottom
of the phone and in particular this is
at least
the exponential of minus s the h1 on
[Music]
so using these spectral things that
some kind of authentication kind of
truncate them you remember that graph i
i wrote earlier there was a graph and
and i want to get rid of some
frequencies so let me um tell you what
you get i mean just by
from this population immediately uh we
so we've got the following
one it says that
same assumptions
then for any s and lambda
if i look at the amount of mass the
spectral mass that s f has in interval
zero lambda this is at most
q s
of f
no this is up to a constant force
this is most
uh
the l to known plus s times lambda
and what you do and okay and and uh well
another proposition i'm not
just say it's brilliant because there's
just one minute um so this is thanks to
liam and dan first and dean van palla
which kind of avoided very much this
localization point of view through 16
and mostly due to chain
um
so they kind of bound uh so for x q s of
x
[Music]
there is some bound for that thing and
now
you can kind of
optimizing s
you get a bound uh
for for uh uh um no f of e lambda so for
any lambda you optimize in so you get
the bound for this thing and then then
comes the the big pleasure so for to
complete the proof
i just take really one more minute
then you just argue as follows you say
that uh um okay we had if you remember
sigma n squared was at most
the h1 norm of that thing
f is x
okay this is the h minus one norm of x
right but this just equals
the integral of the spectral measure of
x
okay over uh uh formula one to infinite
oval on the square
this is just some identity and if you
just plug in the bounds that we get here
there you get well whatever you get
sigma into smaller power
eight over five which is more than two
and then you're kind of done
i showed you the kind of scheme of
things about
used in the proof so this is what i want
to say and thanks for attention
i'm done
yeah wake up
okay yeah
thanks
yes
any questions for boys
let's uh thank god again
thank you thanks for doing it